huge trigger warning folks lots of
problematic diet tips ahead
[Music]
hey everyone I'm Abby sharp welcome to
Abby's kitchen I get sent a lot at Daisy
Keach videos legit every single one on
every platform and a lot of you tell me
that you feel super triggered by her
content and some of her suggestions so I
thought we would pack one of her recent
Vlogs safely together and don't forget
to hit up my description for a free
Hunger crushing ebook and for a link to
unlocked Fitness my recommended
dietitians for one-on-one science-based
Fitness and weight loss management below
let's hold that thought so I can quickly
tell you about today's sponsor genucel
skin care so I would say in like the
last three years since giving birth I've
gotten a lot more serious about my
skincare routine I don't know if like
motherhood just did a real number of me
or it's just because I have to see
myself every single day in the media but
I am now very invested in finding the
best products for my skin and genucel
really has something for everyone their
skincare line is formulated by a
pharmacist with his one-of-a-kind base
and it's all made with Whole Food based
anti substance and while of course they
offer a wide range of skin care products
for anti-aging effects there's a lot of
options for maintaining strong smooth
skin earlier on as well I love their
Ultra retinol because it's specifically
for sensitive skin like mine and I use
their therapy for bags and puffiness
that's made with Swiss Apple extracts
literally every day I normally have a
really hard time finding skincare creams
because of my sensitive skin but all of
their products feel so good and they
have a lot of great packages and
individual options for specific skin
concerns so if you're looking up your
skincare routine right now genucel skin
care has an incredible deal on their
summer Essentials package this is a
great chance to try out some of their
best sellers at a reduced price
especially in these hotter months when
our skin is usually extra stressed out
so you can use my code Abby today for an
extra discount go to genucel.com Abby
and use my code Abby right now at
checkout for this limited time
introductory offer that is g-e-n-u-c
cel.com Abby promo code Abby Abbey and
let me know which products you guys are
loving that I should try next okay folks
let's do it today I'm going to show you
how I prep for a shoot I have something
really exciting coming out that I've
been working really hard on and so I
want to make sure that I look my best
for it okay so to set the stage this
video is all about what Daisy eats when
she's trying to lean out for a special
occasion which in this case is either a
shoot or a vacation or maybe both
whatever it's for you guys know that I
believe in body autonomy so no shame or
judgment for me if leaning out brings
Daisy Joy amazing if it works for her it
works for me I thought about some other
things that I do to get ready for shoots
and usually I will cut up things that
make me really bloated oh bloating my
favorite topic okay so I had to go back
in my old notes but Daisy these chicken
sausages a lot so it really wasn't hard
for me to figure out what she was
talking about so these chicken sausages
are low in fat and high in protein with
12 grams and 80 calories per length that
said they are pretty high in sodium two
sausages contribute just under half the
official recommended sodium for the day
even though side note Daisy probably
actually needs a lot more than the
general suggested limit so for healthy
individuals especially active ones I'm
personally not concerned about salt that
said I get that there's an aesthetic
that she's concerned about and if she's
not drinking a lot of water with the
sausages the salt May temporarily
contribute to some water retention which
might give the puffy look that she
doesn't want these are so puffy and I'm
going to speak more about that in a
moment it's also possible that the onion
seasoning May contribute some fodmaps
which may cause legitimate bloating if
she's sensitive I also haven't been
having as much salt as normal there are
so many different schools of thought
when it comes to sodium cutting and the
best time in a prep to do it but when I
asked my colleague Eric Williamson he
suggested that there's not a whole lot
of point in messing with sodium
especially this far out from an event
sodium depletion is very unlikely to
significantly improve appearance or lead
to further dehydration because sodium
levels are actually highly controlled in
the body most of our bodily fluid is
intracellular not extracellular so if we
dehydrate our cells we're mainly going
to end up with less dense looking
muscles which maybe is the look she
likes but in the bodybuilder world for
example this can leave people looking
soft I am flexing if anything Eric
recommends like a gram of salt right
before the shoot but no changes in
sodium intake in the days or weeks
leading up and I agree I mean a low salt
diet is miserable and also not great for
performance or how you feel I would
personally be focusing on the foods that
trigger IBS bloating I cut down on the
steak too and I think that's been
helping
I think she said cut down on steak which
based on some of her comments later on
in the video I assume this is about
reducing fat and calories I'm personally
not an advocate for consuming a lot of
beef period mainly for environmental
reasons though I do think that there is
a variety of good reasons to cut back
but if she did want her steak and she
was trying to maximize her protein to
calorie ratio her best bet would be to
go for something like a sirloin tip or
top sirloin which are higher in protein
and lower in fat and calories I also cut
out almond milk because I found every
time I'd have my matcha I'd get super
bloated and then I tried matcha with
like whole milk instead whole raw milk
and no bloating so I cut that out and
that's been helping oh my God first and
foremost folks please do not drink raw
milk like period please no no
no ever just don't it is really
irresponsible for influencers to be
promoting unpasteurized milk when we
know that within a 20-year period raw
milk has caused over 2 600 illnesses and
230 hospitalizations most of which have
occurred in young people like kids and
teens contrary to what raw milk enthusia
yes will tell you raw milk isn't better
for lactose intolerance it doesn't treat
allergy or asthma it is not better for
your bones and it's also not better for
your gut because the bacteria present in
raw milk are not probiotic I know Daisy
has struggled with acne and there is an
association between Dairy and acne for
some folks but raw milk still contains
the same milk proteins that can promote
excess igf-1 that's thought to be
responsible for the acne risk consuming
raw milk will do nothing but increase
your risk of serious disease as for the
Almond versus whole milk for bloating
situation I would guess that the
bloating may be due to a sensitivity to
one or more additives in the almond milk
a lot of non-dairy milks contain things
like carrageenan or other stabilizers
and these additives tend to get a lot of
negative buzz and health circles about
their impact on gut permeability and an
increased risk of bowel disease but at
this time the evidence that we have on
this is largely done on rats or
simulators it doesn't mean that it isn't
coming I mean we're hoping that we will
eventually have some more human research
in this area and anecdotally some people
with sensitive tummies find that
excessive amounts of these additives can
cause diarrhea gas or bloating so if she
tolerates whole milk better and it
doesn't aggravate her acne then I think
that sounds like an excellent choice as
long as it's pasteurized I have my
matcha it's just matcha with honey and
cinnamon and whole milk since I am
having whole milk throughout the day I
do try and watch out for the amount of
fats that I eat and like my other meals
and stuff so I try and stay low fat
besides that I think if we're trying to
put ourselves in a calorie deficit to
lean out then reducing fat consumption
is a fair way to do it the differences
in weight loss between low fat and low
carb are negligible at best so whatever
is most sustainable generally seems to
be best and that can be highly
individualized and since Daisy is so
active and therefore really could use
the extra carbohydrates to fuel her
workouts in recovery I agree that
prioritizing protein and carbs over fat
it's probably ideal for my food I have
this yummy
salad right here so in my salad there's
cucumbers there's walnuts was this
really yummy like sweet dressing there's
an avocado there's double chicken on
here and one strawberry one whole
strawberry okay the salad looks
delicious we got lots of fiber in the
veg healthy fats in the nuts and avocado
protein in the chicken love it but
considering this is the first meal of
the day this absolutely could use some
carbs we know that since we're more
insulin sensitive in the morning it's
actually advantageous to front load our
carbs earlier on in the day and then
they did give me some bread that I took
one part out of
um I probably should stop that but it's
so good you guys know how I feel about
this it's disappointing to me that an
influencer with so much power is
demonizing like a hearty nutritious food
to want to eat something but to
explicitly say I should probably stop at
one bite is the definition of
significant restriction to to mean
there's no reason why bread can't fit
into Daisy's vacation prep diet I mean
restriction like this is really a setup
for an obsessive relationship with food
and generally speaking in my experience
it can result in overeating long term
and honestly I don't care what Daisy
does like I guess she's got her goals
and if this works for her cool but it's
the implicit or in this case even
explicit message that she shares with
her young impressionable viewers that in
order to go on a vacation or have photos
taken of you that you need to lean out
and in order to lean out you need to eat
no more than a single bite of bread this
is not good I want to go to the gym
freaking tired but I'm gonna go anyways
because
no pain no gain
oh
free I mean continue to exercise while
exhausted AKA overreaching can
eventually put you at risk of over
training and over training can impair
your immune system cause insomnia
increase cortisol cause loss of period
and can even reduce lean muscle mass all
of this will likely result in the
opposite of desired effect I'm not
saying that Daisy's going to end up over
training or losing her period just
because she was tired and pushed through
one time but 15 percent of female
athletes will suffer from over training
and if our body is chronically
overworked and underfed we significantly
increase that risk I'm just gonna heat
up some frozen rice on the stove maybe
like a cup or something I like to have
like a pretty big carb before my workout
like 20 minutes before and I find this I
have it like 20 minutes before I have
like the best workout and I feel super
strong so I love that Daisy has found
something that works for her and that
we're finally seeing some carbs in
action everyone's energy response to
food is fuel before a big workout will
be different but generally speaking here
are some pre-workout tips depending on
when you work out and when you eat so if
you have several hours before your
training and you can have a much bigger
meal you'll want to generally balanced
hunger crush and combo meal high fiber
carbs protein and healthy fats if you're
eating a meal like an hour or so before
training you want to find a balance
between simple carbs and fiber too much
fiber and you're going to feel bloated
too many simple carbs and you're going
to crash mid workout so you ideally want
a combination of complex carbs like oats
with a quicker digesting option like
banana plus a source of protein and if
you need a boost right before a workout
like Daisy's doing a lower fiber carb
like white rice will give you more
immediate energy without weighing you
down or causing digestive distress some
folks might need an even higher GI carb
like an energy drink over something like
white rice but if this works for Daisy
we love it it works for me I'm using
this rice this is the steam jasmine rice
I mean you can microwave this I
personally don't like to microwave it
one because it comes in like a little
plastic bag and I don't think that like
is healthy for you there have long been
concerns about Foods cooked with plastic
and honestly for good reason the concern
stems from the fact that some chemicals
in Plastics and other packaging like
bpas phthalates and pfas can leach into
our food and the likelihood of that
happening is a lot greater when that
food is heated up so the endocrine
Society has recently warned that these
forever chemicals can interact with our
hormones and research has linked them to
an increased risk of cancer
neurodevelopmental deficits infertility
diabetes immune dysfunction and obesity
so honestly all valid reasons to be
concerned about putting Plastics in like
the microwave but what about foods that
are meant to be cooked in the plastic or
packaging so think about things like TV
dinners boiling bag rice steaming bag
veggies microwavable popcorn Etc I
couldn't find any details on the website
about the rice that Daisy specifically
using but another brand stated that
their product was BPA free and FDA
approved which I actually assume is true
for all of these kinds of products the
challenges we're just starting to
understand the risks of the properties
of these endocrine disrupting chemicals
and because it'll be like totally
unethical to specifically test them in a
randomized control trial on a human
we're basing our knowledge off of subpar
correlations that said if there is a
risk of endocrine disruptors in these
plastic wrap products microwave versus
boiling on the stovetop in the packaging
probably wouldn't matter both might be a
concern I don't know we'll have to see
honestly if you're worried I would just
suggest putting it into a bowl with an
ice cube and microwaving a la Emily
Mariko or emptying it into a pod with a
little extra water to reste I just
realized I was eating dinner and I
didn't show you what I made this is just
some ground beef
pasta sauce and some buns and noodles
this looks delicious and a really good
balance of carbs and protein for
post-workout recovery I normally would
recommend adding in a vegetable like
some sauteed zucchini or mushrooms or
whatever you have on hand but I also
understand that Daisy's concerned about
bloating so maybe she's trying to limit
certain veggies that said most people
would probably be better off using like
a whole grain noodle over the chickpea
pasta she knows her body's tolerance to
fodmaps best and if she tolerates beans
and legumes better than veggies then
Great Soul fiber looks great to me my
tea right there
um I have a dandelion for digestion and
then I have a um chamomile I think I
don't know I put three wait yeah I put a
chamomile and then I also put a lemon
balm
this sounds like a really nice relaxing
evening ritual as supplements chemma and
lemon balm do have some evidence to
support their use for things like
relaxation and sleep whereas dandelion
tea is actually a diuretic so it's often
used to drop water weight which might
fit into Daisy's Mo of looking lean
interestingly it's also been studied in
mice as a weight loss drug that kind of
works similar to the weight loss drug
orlistat though obviously we would need
a lot more research to determine its use
in humans and you would likely need to
consume a ton to see any kind of
clinical benefits and if you're doing
that and you do lose weight the main
reason would probably because you just
filled up on a lot of water
so let's sum all this up as succinctly
and respectfully and kindly as possible
I will say it again I believe in body
autonomy if you want to lose weight for
health reasons great if you want to lose
weight for a vacation also great
whatever brings you Joy you do you but
as influencers we have to be careful
with the content that we put out there
and videos like this suggest to Young
impressional fans that you need to eat
less than 1500 calories you need to have
just two modest meals with no more than
a single bite of bread you need to train
even when you're exhausted in the days
before a photo shoot or a family trip
and I don't love that message so this is
just by a friendly reminder to all of
you out there as we get into summer that
all bodies are bikini bodies you can
have more than a single bite of bread
and you don't have to go to the gym if
you don't feel like it and on that note
that's
awesome don't forget to subscribe to
this Channel and check out my free
Hunger crushing combo ebook and I'll see
you next time on Abby's kitchen bye